with arts now lost to the world we
transformed a tiny outpost into
Dragonstone a fortress fit for the last
dragon lords then Aenar's descendant
settled into it like a tomb for their
lost homeland until Aegon when he looked
east he saw the past old tired dead but
when he lived west he saw the future
gold in the ground gold in the fields
and no dragons in the sky but his he and
his sisters Rhaenys and Visenya flew
over the great continent ostensibly
visitors to a strange land but when
Aegon returned he ordered construction
of a massive table carved in the shape
of Westeros with all the notable rivers
and mountains that they had seen a
personal map of the Seven Kingdoms then
ruled by seven squabbling families
house-door ndon held the Stormlands from
their seated storm's end due south of
Dragonstone house horror of the Iron
Islands had also conquered and enslaved
the Riverlands and ruled them from
Harrenhal
a monstrous castle rising on the shore
of the Gods aye
how stark held the frozen wasteland of
the North the oldest largest and
emptiest of the kingdom has Lannister
held the westerland's the wealthiest
Kingdom
thanks to their gold mines house
gardener held the reach of the second
wealthiest Kingdom thanks to their crops
House Arryn held the Vale or rather the
Vale held them the mountains were
impossible except through the bloody
gate which had never been taken house
Martell held the deserts of dome from
the plate because no one else wanted
them together the Seven Kingdoms made
Westeros a realm that wasn't yet around
ruled by great families who didn't know
what greatness was Aegon would teach
them welcome back everyone it's Charlie
we have awesome news about Game of
Thrones they just picked up the brand
new prequel series about the history of
the Targaryen family called house of
dragons straight to series they ordered
10 episodes for season 1 which means
they want all the seasons to have 10
episodes we know a whole bunch about it
so I'll break all the details down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the bonus videos of
course I'll be doing episode videos and
book Easter eggs for the series when it
gets here and I'll do bonus videos
before it gets here too we do have an
early timeline for when they're going to
be casting when it's going into
production and when they're actually
going to premiere the series so I'll
just do this top ten style like I would
normally do a game of Thrones video
starting with number 10 the name of the
series House of the Dragon is based on
fire and blood if you haven't read that
book George RR Martin published it last
year is basically all this extra
Targaryen history that he wrote while he
was writing the main series winds of
winter he's still working on right now
eventually he just compiled so much
extra history in details about these
characters that he just stuck it all in
a book and called it fire in blood and
it's only part 1 there will be a part
two because part 1 really only goes up
through the end of the dance of the
Dragons
but number 9 who's making the series in
what's Martin's involvement very
important they announced the series is
being co-created with George rr Martin
and Ryan Condal miguel Sapochnick is
actually going to be co show runner with
Ryan Condal in George RR Martin is going
to be an executive producer which he was
not on the main series during
the first four seasons of the main show
George RR Martin did get to give a lot of
script notes and tell them when they
were getting things wrong he wrote an
episode per season eventually what
happened is what you all saw is that it
hurt his progress on the main series of
books he was able to finish Dance with
Dragons during those first four seasons
but because winds of winter was taking
so much longer he had to back away from
the main show after season four they
didn't say whether or not Martin would
be writing scripts for the new series
but I'm assuming for now that he's just
providing a lot more creative oversight
and having a bigger say in what actually
happens than he did on the original show
but pretty safe bet that he'll probably
write an episode or two over the course
of the series if it runs seven to eight
seasons number eight though miguel
Sapochnik very important get for this
series he was one of the best creatives
behind some of the best of the best
Game of Thrones episodes on the original
series that's probably one of the
reasons why HBO is moving so quickly on
this Targaryen prequel there was another
prequel that they cancelled recently
I'll talk about that in a second but
sipar chanak didn't start working on the
main series until season five but he did
the gift hardhome battle of the bastards
in winds of winter in season six and
then he was forced to skip season seven
because of family issues but came back
and directed the long night episode
three during season eight in that
episode five the bells
so he's mostly known for doing the
biggest craziest in a lot of cases what
you would consider the best episodes of
Game of Thrones so I'm really happy that
he's gonna be Kosho runner so super
powerful person on the new series but
for the most part he's probably going to
be spending most of his time on set
managing that aspect of creative his
partner Ryan Condal and george RR martin
are probably gonna be spending most of
their time riding the series they had to
show runners Dan and Dave on the main
show they still have to show runners in
the new series but you have the addition
of George rr Martin himself who is also
providing way more creative oversight in
case you missed it after season 8 I did
a video about Miguel Sapochnick's
deleted scenes that he talked about I'll
post a link to that at the end of this
video because the stuff that he says
will blow your mind number 7 when does
this house of the Dragon series actually
take place most reports all the news
outlets that are reporting this in the
trades are saying it takes place 300
years ago which would put it right at a
cons conquest because they say they're
chronicling the
targaryen conquest of the seven kingdoms
but it will also eventually encompass
the dance of the Dragons here's the
thing if you know your game of Thrones
history obviously Aegon's conquest 300
plus years ago but the dance of the
Dragons Targaryen Civil War was about a
hundred and twenty nine years ago so
there's either gonna be some massive
time jumps during the series or it's
going to be an anthology series which
HBO did not say they didn't say anything
about anthology so unless they really
are jumping through time many years each
season they might just be handling all
the stuff in the past like Aegon's
conquest using flashbacks the way that
the main show handled Robert's rebellion
so most of season one may be season two
will be dedicated to telling the story
of Aegon's conquest they didn't say
anything about covering the earlier
period in ancient history like the doom
of Valyria or the period before the doom
but as is the style with Game of Thrones
characters discuss history and tell
stories like old man events that
happened in the past so there will be
some old nan type character probably a
dragon stone or one of the other castles
telling tales of the doom also keep in
mind that because this was 300 years ago
this is still thousands of years after
the long night the building of the wall
and the establishment of the Nights
Watch so all that's happening up in the
north long before Aegon ever conquered
the Seven Kingdoms number six the early
seasons Aegon's conquest of the six
kingdoms because remember he didn't
conquer Dorne so he only conquered six
of the seven kingdoms the intro at the
beginning of this narrated by Viserys
Targaryen himself kind of gives you the
small part of their early history after
fleeing the doom of Valyria after Danice
the dreamer had a vision foretelling the
Cataclysm but Aegon himself Aegon the
conquerer was a few generations removed
from a gnar Targaryen the Targaryen that
took them to Dragonstone fleeing the
doom leading up to the actual conquest
as a younger man Aegon spent a lot of
time flying his dragon balerion the
black dread with his sisters before they
went full sister wiping all over the
Seven Kingdoms so they spent a lot of
time in Westeros before they set it on
fire
Aegon was so fascinated with Westeros
that he actually commissioned the giant
map table that's why the formal name of
this room is called the chamber of the
painted table we spent a lot of time in
Dragonstone across the series mostly
during season seven
they really only built out bigger sets
in different rooms for Season seven like
the throne room so hopefully they'll use
it as an opportunity to build out other
big sets and other places with in
Dragonstone the same way they did for
Winterfell in the early seasons there
are a number of castles from present-day
that we saw in the main show that were
being built or were already built by the
time Aegon conquer the Seven Kingdoms
Harrenhal is probably the most infamous
in fact the day that he finished
building the castle and took up
residence was the same day that Aegon
Targaryen made landfall at the site that
is now known as King's Landing that's
why it's called King's Landing because
that's where the future King landed his
army within a year of that he had taken
balerion the black dread to burn
Harrenhal melting most of its towers in
some say cursing it forever but for
after Aegon's conquest the major events
that the show would cover or probably
will cover depending on how long they
want to spend on each event would be the
rise of Aegon sons the first Dornish war
the faith militant uprising maegor the
cruel building the dragon pit the very
first Great Council which was actually
held at Harrenhal after King Joe Harris
the wisest son Balin died because he
didn't have another heir he had to name
another successor so Great Council was
called all the Lords of the realm
assembled to try and compel King Joe
Harris to pick another successor then
they billed through several other big
tragedies that lead up to the dance of
the Dragons so 3 the actual dance of the
Dragons the Targaryen Civil War lasted
for about two years so presumably if the
new show runs for seven or eight seasons
the last two seasons at least would be
spent telling that story if not more
seasons there's no rule that says that
each season of the show has to cover an
entire year of the timeline so they can
actually spend the last half of the
series during the dance of the dragons
if they want if you're not familiar with
the dance of the dragons it was the
first major civil war in the history of
the Seven Kingdoms it was basically a
war of succession between aegon ii and
his half-sister rhaenyra targaryen
over their fathers throne the two
different-sized were referred to as the
blacks in the greens and because this is
a period in history when there are a lot
of dragons you wind up off a lot
of dragons during this event so if
you're a big fan of dragons on the main
show this show in the last couple of
seasons will have more dragons fighting
each other in the air than you've ever
seen before
also around the time of the dance of the
Dragons there was a war in the East
called the daughters war that was being
fought over territory controlled by an
organization called the tri our key so
you could also cover things that are
happening in Essos bouncing back and
forth between continents just like the
main show did during the early seasons -
I know you're all asking when a season
one going to premiere when are they
gonna announce the cast and when will
they start shooting it because they
picked it up straight to series that
means that HBO is moving super fast
they only do stuff like that when they
want episodes as quickly as possible
given the amount of time it took to
finish special effects in the amount of
time it normally used to take to make
seasons of the main show as long as they
cast it and start shooting by next
summer they can get episodes out by
April 20-21 Game of Thrones was always
intended to be a spring early summer
show I would plan on the new prequel
series being the same but number one I
know you're asking there was supposed to
be a long night prequel series they even
shot a pilot episode what happened to
that just a couple days ago before they
announced this new series they announced
that they had cancelled the long night
prequel series but I think it's clearly
a dragon's vs. no dragons situation so I
will do more bonus videos as we get more
information but leave all your big
questions and your video requests in the
comments everybody click here for that
Game of Thrones season 8 deleted scenes
video with a really cool interview from
Miguel Sapochnik check and click here for
my giant game of Thrones playlist with
all my bonus videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight!